Tobias Elwood is with us now I think
especially that good morning Mr Elwood I
think it's fair to say you're no friend
Boris Johnson but does he deserve this
uh we need to be careful what we say the
Privileges committee have an important
job to do can we well this is the point
we need to be careful here because it
isn't just the media that's interested
in this the nation is watching and he
did further afield across the world
Parliament has a very solid reputation
and we need to up hold that so let the
Privileges committee do its job we then
of course have to vote on that depending
on that outcome and it's important that
despite what we think about the
personality there we shouldn't be
dazzled or distracted uh by who this is
we need to allow the Privileges
committee to do that job and then MPS
can then follow up from there I separate
that from whether Boris Johnson was
appropriate suitable to be in number 10
or be removed as well it became very
very clear and it was reflected in the
polls that because of Owen Patterson I
think it was the start of it that he was
desensitizing the way number 10 operated
he was actually becoming I think
ill-disciplined there was a lack of
focus lack of determination a lack of
clarity as to where the country was
going to go and it became very partisan
and populist that's very separate from
whether at the dispatch box Boris
Johnson was misleading Parliament and
that's for the privilege privileges
committee to determine and we should
allow them to get on with that job yeah
but that privileges committee I mean
your chair of the committee aren't you
the defense select committee um it's
loaded in favor of you guys there's four
of you as opposed to three others are
you now inviting me to then make comment
on the Privileges committee as as well
if if you don't mind it is best and I
encourage all other MPS to recognize the
fact that it will be it will damage
parliament's reputation if the process
is sin to somehow to be influenced or so
is not as impartial as it should be what
do you think
um the House of Commons
um known as the mother of all
parliaments what do you think their
reputation is overseas at the moment
well for many reasons including what's
happened with the brexit debate which
I'm pleased you know away from what's
going on in that committee room we are
voting on the um on the Windsor
framework we're not really are you are
voting on one particular aspect yes but
it's part and parcel of us drawing a
line under the whole brexit issue which
has troubled us and overseas you ask the
question has looked as if we've
retreated from the global States what
we've done in Ukraine is to show
actually what we prefer to do is to be
an influencer help shape Global events
not be internally domestically focused
because that's the way we went and I
have to say that's the way the United
States went that's very dangerous for
democracy it's been watched by our
adversaries not least China and Russia
that want to exploit this and rewrite
our rules-based order what about the
Russians saying well these weapons that
you're thinking of sending to Ukraine or
what's then the tip of those and this is
not a good idea well I'm glad you asked
about that because this is I'm glad you
like some of my questions
that's this is my comfort zone it's
talking about you know UK security and
to have Putin say that he's going to
respond because we're using a depleted
uranium shells Russia uses these same
very same shells they're used across the
world so this is inflammatory I'd invite
the international atomic energy agency
to clarify that this is not provocative
from a nuclear perspective this has
nothing to do with nuclear bombs
tactical nuclear fissile material you
can't make a nuclear weapon out of
depleted uranium shells this is about
Putin ratcheting up and I think
provoking his own population who
probably know little about this to say
this is what Britain's doing and of
course you've got China president XI
visiting the adversary backing Russia as
well we're in a very dangerous place at
the moment it's fundamental that we
allow Ukraine to win here because if
Putin is able to declare victory that
will support China China is going to
have an Almighty clash with the United
States in our lifetimes in some form or
another and China wants Russia or
particularly Putin on uh their side
that's why he's over in presidency is
over in Moscow right now what is so is
it his I have in my hand a piece of
paper moment and he wants to broker a
deal between a peace deal between uh
Russia and Ukraine oh he wants to do
exactly that but why do you want to then
broker a peace deal when Russia is
claiming one-fifth of Ukraine that's not
an independent impartial view that a
superpower that's a permanent member of
the United Nations security Council
should be promoting China has clearly
now declared its cards to support Putin
to support Russia and I've said this
many times here that our world is slowly
progressively splintering into two
spheres of influence and we've been too
slow in recognizing where it's going two
of the five members of the UN Security
Council there you know they and they're
getting together and they're trying to
come up with a peace deal isn't that
their job it's their job to then
recognize also that one state cannot
attack another state illegally in
today's day and age without consequences
so what China is trying to do is saying
right let's sit down as things are as
the status quo is that actually then
rewards the bully for what they've done
and don't forget China is watching very
carefully at the precedent that the West
sets because it's got its eye on Taiwan
so how do we solve the challenge that is
Ukraine absolutely we need to lean in
and make sure Ukraine wins flushes out
Russia from its territory not just Don
bass but the Crimea as well that is
taking us so you think the war only ends
when they're out of Crimea absolutely
100 if there's any part of Ukraine which
is left in Russia's hands Russia Putin
can declare a victory Putin then
survives he everything calms down and he
does it he regroups rearms and does it
all again in another part of Europe
Ukraine is just the battle there is a
bigger War taking place in Europe and we
really haven't quite understood that you
read the integrated review refresh as
it's called this document by the
government they make it very very clear
how dangerous our world you know is
heading unfortunately we haven't backed
that up crime has been in that position
for the last eight years and NATO didn't
do much about it oh you're absolutely
right and it's it's not just then it's
the last 30 years since the end of the
Cold War that we've progressively become
more risk-averse Afghanistan was a great
example of that where we eventually gave
up Libya uh Syria Iraq Somalia Yemen all
these places that we've wandered into
and then lost the Strategic patience the
commitment to see it through and of
course they've then the governances
because they've Fallen apart as a
security and so forth they become
problem States and ironically you then
have migration coming from these places
as well so since the end of the Cold War
we've lost our focus our purpose of what
it means to be part of the West what we
believe in what we stand for what we're
willing to defend okay which way you're
going to vote today for the storm won't
break absolutely in favor and I'd
encourage all
parliamentarians to to lean into that we
need to recognize there was always going
to be a problem with this going back to
the referendum when you have part of the
UK with a land border with the EU the
people that did recognize this
ironically were David Frost Boris
Johnson Dan Hannah Nigel farage because
they wanted to stay in the single Market
which would have meant all these
problems go away but of course we moved
to a harder kind of brexit so that then
was was removed but thankfully which is
sunac has reduced statecraft back in to
number 10 managed to square those
circles build those bridges and get an
answer I really do encourage all MPS to
support this it's what Northern Ireland
wants 40 of norland's trade is goes
south so they absolutely want this to
work we want to actually move forward
and draw a line under this you're a fan
of Ed Sheeran's music Ed Sheeran's music
it was not a question I was expecting to
have but yes no I'm glad because we've
got some thanks for joining us thank you